près de
2,3
nous élus d'aujourd'hui me
[Musique]
quand j'ai regardé dans sa cabane
j'ai vu que son sac et elle a
ses vêtements étaient là
j'ai cru comprendre que vous aviez
beaucoup voyagé vous êtes allé en libye
en irak ce que vous savez des raisons de
croire que c'est à cause de mon métier
ce qui est arrivé à mon président nous
envisageons toutes les hypothèses
y compris dans le vent
que tu as pensé une seconde au genre de
père que tu as été pourtant fille je
suis un mauvais père je sais que je ne
suis pas présent
je crois que j'ai trouvé une piste
regarde ces deux images
14 heures je reçois un appel de la
personne la plus haut placée de la
police écossaise et il me demande de me
retirer de la sphère qu'on ne pouvait
compter que sur vous monsieur noël
moi ce que je veux savoir
oui bon m